let's get off the poseurs you know I've
always been suspicious of friends what
starts over a shared interest in
paintball comes to a screeching halt
four years later when I have to memorize
your wife's name
nice ride Gary why don't you go home to
blond hair and blue shoes friends are
dangerous and no one knows that more
than America's number-one friend Donald
Trump he went to the g7 summit this
weekend which in case you don't know is
where the u.s. meets with our top allies
to discuss the world economy and
diplomatic priorities so you know what
Trump did ask in force he body slammed
it that's not hyperbole this is actual
footage of Trump walking into the summit
yeah here he is walking it and it is
there is Edie slam slam take that
that'll teach you to be ideologically
alived with us on almost every
geopolitical issue now of course the
leftist media sees some sort of problem
with this the Trump is alienating all
his allies and acting like a petulant
child but does this look like a petulant
child this is obviously a power stance
everyone knows the real way to be in
charge is to make your body resemble a
pouty mini refrigerator but get used to
a world for everyone wondering what the
Trump foreign policy doctrine is history
got an answer three words senior White
House official quoted today the Trump
doctrine is we're America bitch
where America bitch what a doctrine now
I know there's a word in there that
liberals will find offensive America
those bitches need to chill this is what
we're America bitch looks like you show
up whenever the hell you want to Trump
left late for the summit on Friday
landing an hour behind schedule
when asked hype why he was late one
White House official told NBC News quote
he's the president he again showed up
late this time 20 minutes late for
breakfast discussion on gender equality
they should be happy the meeting was at
gender equality so Trump graciously only
participated in 77% of it he didn't stop
there Trump took his doctrine to
America's upstairs neighbor Canada
Canada drives me crazy it's like
somebody took Bernie Sanders and
stretched him into an entire country
and yeah and it's led by Prime Minister
swimming-pool
eyes Justin Trudeau who said himself and
his country up as America's enemy number
one a few with canvas a prime minister
Justin Trudeau just heating up Canada
maybe the closest us a line promised
retaliatory trade moves in response to
steep new tariffs announced by the Trump
administration Trump firing back calling
Trudeau weak his advisors saying
Canada's Justin Trudeau stabbed the
president in the back you can't stab
Trump in the back he's got eyes back
there he sees everything listen to
Trudeau's vicious vulgar threats
Canadians were polite were reasonable
but we also will not be pushed around oh
I am sorry that everyone at home will
have to wash their DVRs out with soap a
pretty big words from someone who is
taking advantage of America by taxing
dairy from us at 270 percent according
to Trump's Twitter but what does Canada
trying to do to us with this 270 percent
milk tax milk comes in 1% 2% and halt
what kind of a monster country demands
270 percent milk
this is dense like a black hole of
lactose no bean-counting economist nerds
are taking Canada side saying that Trump
is a bully and pointing out that Canada
brings in twice as much dairy from the
US as it exports and that dairy is only
about 0.2% of the total value of goods
exported to Canada but last I checked
one-fifth of 1% is still some so Trump
isn't being a bully he's just pushing
around a smaller weaker kid and
literally stealing his milk money
stop picking on us Canada we're America
bitch
you know what Brooke doesn't have time
for any ug7 nerves because right now the
president is in Singapore sitting down
with kim jeong-hoon negotiating a
historic peace and if they're lucky
North Korea will one day become the type
of ally that we can bodyslam on the
world stage opposers are there any three
words more exciting than click and
subscribe
yes Hillary shot Lincoln subscribe now
and find out the truth they don't want
you to know and by day I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts without
clicking subscribe do it